So you absolutely destroyed that like goal, way
things are going ima probably end up bald before
next year. I've gotta be unreasonable now, 30
thousand likes before the next part of the story
which is the Neo Hero’s Arc in around a month from
now and ill shave my head! This part here though,
the Psychic Sisters arc has probably some of the
greatest moments from throughout the series. Its
not necessarily on the destructive level that
the previous monster association arc was on,
but it comedically had me curling over in pained
laughter. Everything is just brilliant and ima
glaze the goats Murata and One so hard with
this video. It feels like season one with
just how world breaking of a person Saitama is,
everything that comes his way is just played off
like a joke. Of course remember to subscribe if
you are new around here and want content just
like this but for a variety of different series,
but for now time to sit back and enjoy the video!
Kicking things back off, right outside a large
apartment in the Hero New Association Base,
Butterfly DX, Forte and Chain'n'toad decide to
visit their new freak of a neighbor. They call
out to him and ring his doorbell, thinking
he might be a rookie they can outshine as
more experienced heroes. To their surprise, the
door swings open, and King stands before them,
instilling fear in the trio as they come to
the realization that Saitama isn't home at all.
Elsewhere throughout the one punch man world and
amidst the destroyed landscape of the previous
battle site, a lone helicopter spots a certain
hero. Down below and rummaging through the sea
of rubble, Pig God is searching for something,
confusing everyone in the helicopter. Close-by,
the weird meetup is spotted by Black S who’s
currently hiding inside of the rubble. With
all of the hero’s in the helicopter yelling
out to Pig God telling him that he needs rest,
the S-Class hero decides to run
off. Randomly and of course Black-S
notices Pig God running in his direction and
hides to not be found. The representative,
annoyed at the S-Class heroes' self-centered
nature, is then met by the A-Class hero Air,
who claims he’ll take the
job of capturing big pig god!
Claiming that all he needs is 5 minutes
to finish the wounded Pig off, Air rushes
forward. As he gets closer, the A-Class
comments on the pathetic state of all of
these so called pillars. From what he’s heard
they were all taken out by the Hero Hunter,
they’re spoiled and neglected their
training. Getting up to the large Hero,
he demands Pig God return or face him to gain
his freedom. Overhearing what the dudes saying,
the representative becomes anxious
over how this happens every damn time.
Suddenly, something moves amongst
the rubble nearby. Revealing itself,
the object turns out to be none other than
a severely reduced Evil Natural Water. Its
appearance doesn't faze Air but stuns Pig God
who knows of the monsters true capabilities. Air,
non-chalantly decides to deal with the little
monster first and launches his boomerang,
only for the demon level threat to shoot a beam
of water, that penetrates through the boomerang
and Air's throat with complete ease. Black-S
who was hiding within a few feet of the group,
sees the scuffle and is shocked to
see his fellow monster still alive.
Without Hesitation Pig God quickly swallows
Evil Natural Water, seemingly ending the
monsters existence. Randomly a plethora of
water beams shoot out of pig god in every
direction. Concerned, the representative
asks what the hell he just swallowed,
however Pig God explains that its okay now
because the monster is digested. The dude
tries getting the S-Class hero to return and
get examined by the docs, but he points out
that the helicopter cant even hold him. Instead
he intends to visit a ramen shop. Walking off now,
he points out that a survey of the area
should be done to find any surviving monsters.
Over with Black-S itself and realizing
that they are extremely low on cell stocks,
runs away deeper into the destroyed area to
find somewhere to hide. As he walks he cant
help but be shocked at the Monster Association's
downfall. He continues his search for something
to eat and gain a few extra lives when
suddenly, he sees Saitama in the distance.
Saitama himself is overjoyed at the situation,
as after days of searching he’s finally found
the remains of his destroyed apartment.
Knowing that this man is he, himothy,
Black-S hides in sheer terror. After everything,
the last person he wanted to bump into was the
naked man who knocked out the Awakened Garou
with a single punch. To his horror, the the duo's
attention is moved towards the now much smaller
Overgrown Rover. Looking down on the trio now,
Black-S is baffled that somehow Pochi survived.
As he watches the monoliths of strength tower over
the pup, he can only feel sorry for the poor thing
and also reasons that it would be wise for him to
leave. Bizarrely and just before leaving, he see’s
Saitama stick his hand out and pick up Rover. He
notices that instead of instantly killing the
monster, Saitama is treating Rover like an
animal. Thinking about why a man of this strength
wouldn't deal with the threat, he assumes that the
dude is the sort of guy who avoids needless
violence. Realizing that this could actually
be his one chance at survival, Black-S starts
to fixate on what his next action should be.
Meanwhile, Geno’s and Saitama are stuck in
a conversation over how long he’s been a
fan of dogs for, with the latter telling
him that its just a recent occurrence.
Geno’s agree’s that they are extremely cute,
but before he can worry about the cost of
feeding rover, his watch beeps, letting
him know that he’s needed at the Hero
Association. Still stuck in thought, Black-S
believes that even if the monsters come back,
there is no safer place than under the protection
of Saitama. Sucking up his pride, Black-S
eventually leaps out from behind the rubble and
attempts to join the bald kings group of muppets.
Saitama yells at the newcomer to
stop following him as right now he
can barely take care of this dog, let
alone a weird monkey thing. Black-S
speaks up and tries to convince him
by saying he’ll help with the chores,
but after Saitama begins to walk off, sticks
with the idea of hiding low as his monkey.
Wondering if the apartment even
allowed pets in the first place,
Saitama just assumes that he could put a pog house
outside, exciting Black-S. Questioning the cadre,
Saitama asks if he’s seen a one eyed monster round
these parts. Thinking that he meant, Gyoro Gyoro,
Black-S just claims that it must’ve been
taken out by one of Tatsumaki’s large attacks.
Getting closer, Saitama points out that,
he can see it now. His new home.
Blown away with the tremendous size,
the little monster finally feels like this is a
place he doesn't need to watch his back inside.
Meanwhile, inside the Hero Associations
Headquarters, a presentation is given to
a select few rich members of the public about
the new apartment complexes. Green and Crescent
Eyebroll talk to each other about how its obvious
the association is targeting the rich first. Green
know that if money is able to buy safety, the
recent influx of rich people who are willing
to pay for it is increasing. Crescent points
out that its because monster attacks are on an
unprecedented level these days, even disaster
level demons pop up more than twice a month!
The presentation mentions that the
apartments are impervious to monster
attacks and only A-Class heroes or above with
proven track records can live here as residents,
while simultaneously being bodyguards.
Taking in all the speculative information,
the crowd doesn't reciprocate the same feelings.
They know that even if they’re living with Hero’s,
they’re still human just like them and can
be injured. They can easily wear themselves
out or get caught up in an accident, that in
their eyes certainly cant be called safety.
Sensing the unease of how weak the human
frame is, the presenter moves to a new topic,
the Hero Apartment's secret weapon. Designed
by Metal Knight and using an AI to anticipate,
coordinate and execute the appropriate
response. It is claimed by Metal Knight
that this comprehensive defense
system does a more effective job
at defending the base than all
of the A-Class heroes combined.
Cutting through all of the chatter,
randomly the bases alarm system
detects something nearby and activates.
Outside the Headquarters, Saitama,
Overgrown Rover, and Black S arrive
at a large steel entrance door. The defense
system, sensing the two monsters calculates
their current strength and sends out a
Level 1 response. As the entrance door
opens a gigantic robot walks out and confronts
the trio. Without hesitation, the robot attempts
to eliminate the two monsters with a thundering
left smash. Confused, Saitama blocks the attack,
destroying the arm, before jumping up into
the sky and completely shattering it with a
simple slap. This in turn annihilates the level
one defense system, causing the building's AI
bot to re-adjust its calculations and
send out a lot of level four robots.
Just like before, the robots launch their
attack, firing hundreds of blasts in the
direction of the trio. Black-S and Rover somehow
manage to slip their way through the blasts,
just before Saitama who was completely
unconcerned with the level increase,
adjusted these stupid robots with a quick smack.
Obviously this completely destroys all of
the robots and activates the entire bases
defense system. Inside and freaking out over the
current battle going on right next to an entrance,
the Hero Association sends out an emergency
call for several heroes to deal with the threat.
Confusedly they try and search for the exit
inside of this large new complex. Eventually
they head towards the south and find the correct
entrance doorway. However as they rush outside,
the representative’s see Saitama and
asks what the hell just happened out
here! Saitama tries to tell him that,
well they all randomly exploded,
but gets cut off when another one complains that
those robots took 9 billion each to develop.
Now terrified of dealing with the financial
repercussions of his actions, Saitama weakly
states that they simply exploded. Obviously the
officials dont believe him in the slightest and
ask for every single detail possible on what
just happened here. Cutting the representative
off and backing up the bald king, a familiar
voice tells them that he’s telling the truth.
Of course its KING who states that he saw it
too, all those robots just randomly exploded...
While all of the representatives
are caught up on Kings appearance,
Saitama approaches his mate and gives him back
his video game console, albeit destroyed. EVEN
THOUGH DUDE BROKE IT IN THE FIRST PLACE. Remember
when he got mad and clicked to hard breaking it,
now mans trying to pass it off as damage
from the recent battle. Actual genius.
On top of that and curing his anxiety,
King doesn't mind in the slightest and
had only stopped by his apartment
earlier to see if he wanted to
jam out together. Realizing that its time to feed
his goldfish though, King shoots off. Black S,
who’s hiding underneath Rover, is surprised
to see King's presence, before realizing that
he’s gone and strolled into the Hero Association
Headquarters. Watching nearby, Forte is surprised
to see King talking with a complete nobody.
As the hero wonders who the hell he is, its
shown that after a lot of trials and tribulations,
Saitama has now been promoted to A-Class Rank 39!
Over in the control room of the new HeadQuaters,
a few of the workers talk about how much money
was poured into the design of this place.
They think metal knights done a sloppy job,
as with his robots malfunctioning like that,
its thrown billions of tax payer dollars down
the drain. One of the guys notes that, he’s
gonna share the image data from the security
camera’s with Bofoi, so he’s interested to find
out what excuse he’s gonna come up with this time.
Somewhere else in deep thought, Bofoi cant
understand how Level 4 through 10 of his
robots were completely destroyed. What's more,
the one who did it was a total loser from the Hero
Association, Class-A Rank 39 Caped Baldy. Glancing
over his data, he can see that within 65 days,
Saitama or as they know him, Caped Baldy has
risen through the ranks extremely quickly.
Needing to source more information, the buck
tooth genius cracks into association's database
and discovers that Saitama has helped in a bunch
the most recent battles. Confused on why he was
ranked up so quickly, he finds some hidden remarks
about how early on the man absolutely destroyed
the physical fitness test, becoming the new record
holder. Seeing how easily he destroyed his robots,
Bofoi judges that Saitama is probably
stronger than even an S-Class hero,
and decides to track him, just
incase he becomes a future enemy.
Skipping back to two days ago in an emergency
meeting held, with only Genos, Flashy Flash,
Sweet Mask, Zombieman, Sekingar and Sitch
present. Big Sitch suggests that the recent
events during the Monster Association incident
are linked with the prophecy that the Earth is
in danger. He asks that until they can confirm
their official standing to keep all information
confidential. Geno’s immediately agree’s, but
Zombieman wonders why he even wants to keep
things secret this late in the game. Flashy
Flashy thinks they should remain cautions
as even Hero’s have begun reporting that
anybody at any moment can just transform
into a monster. Already knowing of this info,
Sitch says that its precisely because of this
reason that they need to be certain about a
way to fight it before doing anything publicly.
Sekingar points out that revealing the info to
early could create a form of mass hysteria due
to a wide spread fear and anxiety over not
knowing who might become the next threat.
Having an extremely tight schedule, along with
his pants. Sweet Mask asks for more information
on what they already have, as he doesn't have a
single cue what they are talking about. Geno’s
buts in with a stack of notes and remarks
to the group that he needs to set aside 3
hours to discuss Saitama’s activities during the
battle. Realizing he needs to put Geno’s last,
Sitch asks Zombieman to discuss what was told to
him during his battle against Homeless Emperor.
Sitting there Zombieman mentions
that while homeless emperor was
still human he was given a divine power by
something called “God”. Sitch, Sweet Mask,
and Sekingar are surprised at the mention
of "God", while Geno’s and Flashy Flashy
who weren't too surprised stated that he had
previously encountered something that tried to
offer power and spoke to him telepathically.
This God stated to Sweet that if the vessel
who took this power wasn't worthy, then they
would face forfeiture. Zombieman remembers
and lets everyone know that in his final moments,
Homeless Emperor seemed to be hearing something,
or addressing someone. Flashy takes this
info and the stuff that was given to him by
God and is able to figure out that what killed
homeless emperor was probably the same being.
Sweet Mask speaks up and proposes that "God"
might just be a leader of the Monster Association,
after all the so called Gyoro turned out
to be a human esper. Flashy denies this
as in his opinion it’d be weird that only a
select few cadre’s were granted this power
out of the entire base. The enemies that they
just faced wouldn't be strong enough to force
Blast into chasing this thing through the
shadows of space time. Looking at Sitch now,
Flashy asks for any info on what's actually
going on with him! Not initially saying anything,
Flashy re-iterates what was told to him
by Blast during the previous battle,
causing Sitch to reveals that he has been helping
keep Blast Hidden. For the past twenty years,
Blast has been continuously fighting against
the one they all call God. Blast along with his
intergalactic partners had been searching for
a mysterious cube, that could turn humans into
monsters. This Cube was handed down over time as a
kind of communication device that somewhat allowed
an individual to communicate with God. Blast
was specifically collecting these with his boys
and trying to analyze them. However, 2 years ago
during the infamous battle in which Blast took on
the Elder Centipede. He came into contact with God
directly. Ofcourse like most of the other S-Class
hero’s who’ve been prompted by God, Blast refused
the power and actually pitted himself against God.
At that point in time, the association wasn't
able to hold a candle against such an opponent,
even with everyone working together. To
start with not a single sensor they’ve
created has been able to detect the being.
Once they realized that it would be safer
to have everyone stay un-aware of it, Blast
took off into the expanse of time and tried
his best to protect everyone. Flashy stunned
with the current information he’s receiving,
figured that the Top Ranking hero would
have a good reason for not showing himself.
Genos though, man thinks completely differently.
Jumping into the conversation he lets them know
that if they had just spoken about it sooner, the
Saitama AKA Caped Baldy could have resolved this
already. Actually a goat. Sitch tries to deny
this rock solid information by explaining that
only blast is able to battle god because of his
space-time manipulation ability. Laying his trap
card on the table, Geno’s asks if that is indeed
so? He after all wasn't able to fit this into his
one page report, so instead has decided to bring
a specific tactic up here that he knows will work.
Beginning his long held off rant, the cyborg tells
them each and every detail on what happened in
the fight between Saitama and Garou, along
with his own fate and that of all the other
hero’s. After the grueling four-hour discussion
comes to an end, with Sweet Mask leaving due to
scheduling problems, everyone is exhausted.
Still, they all claim that Genos's intel is
pretty damn wild. Sekingar cant even fathom
how its possible for them to fly to Jupiter,
destroy the entire planet, then fly back. THEN
on top of that the time travel just makes it
all completely fly over their heads. Sitch
mentions they must confer with Saitama for its
authenticity. Yet and like we already know, Geno’s
remarks that Saitama has no memory of the events,
leading Flashy Flash to call Genos'
explanation a lie, enraging the cyborg.
Zombieman instead points out that they could
confer with Garou and confirm it that way. Again
though Sekingar explains that the apparent shock
from the final punch made him lose his memory.
With no definitive info at all, Sitch
states that the one thing they can
confirm is that the interactions with
God’s dimension is rapidly increasing.
Blast assumed that its possible there
might be something in their worlds
dimension that drawing him here. Either way,
Sitch continues explaining that Blast will
soon return and until then their top
priorities are unity and solidarity.
Having completed their meeting, Genos abruptly
leaves, saying that if they do hear anything
from blast, they need to contact Saitama AKA
Mr Caped Baldy immediately. Still super cocky,
Flashy tells Sitch to let blast know that he
needs to hurry up and finish his current fight,
so they can finally throw
down, before also leaving.
Sitting there himself, Zombieman suddenly
remembers back to Dr. Genus's words about
someone losing their hair in exchange for
removing their limiter. Realizing that it
might’ve been the caped baldy, Zombieman
gets ready for the impending future.
Down a nearby hallway, Flashy thought that up
until now, caped baldy was positioned under
Geno’s. After this meeting and having seen
the dudes intense devotion towards Saitama,
it makes him think that its
possible he might be that guy.
Elsewhere and as Sweet Mask makes his way
towards his next scheduled meeting. He
cant help but think that for Geno’s
to be so captivated by Caped Baldy,
he must have what it takes. What
it takes to be the ideal Hero.
Being driven through a mountain road,
Fubuki is asked by Eyelashes why on
earth does she want to go to this place
anyway? Along with the entire Blizzard Group,
fully armed... Looking actually BANGING rn,
Fubuki replies that she plans to meet someone and
there's a slight chance things will turn violent.
Elsewhere, in R-City, Sweet Mask is approached
by a director of a new upcoming idol group.
This group, the bubbly boys are a group
of 7 strong highschool aged students,
with two of them already having
passed the C-Class hero exam.
Having explained this all two him, the
director hopes that Sweet will be able
to give them some advice in surviving
this cutthroat entertainment industry.
Unconcerned with these pathetic nerds, Sweet
just tells them that they have 0 appeal,
none, so dont talk to him. He isn't
interested in phonies. Instead he’s
entirely fixated on looking at his
phone. More specifically the security
camera footage from two days ago which shows
a caped baldy destroying the bases defenses.
After hearing harsh words from the hero that
they’ve based their existence on, the members
of the group start arguing with him, to his
annoyance. He tries explaining to the idiots,
that the title of Hero isn't something
that can be used as a stepping stone. That
way of thinking is exactly why the agency is
already saying the groups difficult to handle.
Wondering what they would do if Sweet was a
monster and appeared infront of them like this,
the group exclaims that they’d lay him out. It’s
7 on 1 and he shouldn't be looking down on them,
the Bubbly Boys. Beginning to
crack up laughing, without warning,
the pathetic boys feel an overwhelming chill
that startles them into silence. Sweet Mask
explains that its their instincts warning them
of how they are too biologically different.
Menacingly staring at them, he sternly lets
them know how disgusting they truly are,
none of them are beautiful, beautiful like him,
the Caped Baldy in all his overwhelming power!
Speaking of the man himself, over inside his
apartment, Saitama finally meets with and
greets fellow A-Class heroes Chain'n'toad,
Butterfly DX, and Forte. After finding out
that Saitama is older than him, Forte claims
he is the senior of the apartment because he
moved in first. Saitama notes though that the
place only opened two weeks ago. Moving past
the teething trouble’s Saitama greets his new
neighbors and tells them about how his place
was recently destroyed. Yet once he became A-Class
and King told him about this shelter, he moved in.
Randomly Chain’n’toad remove’s his furry hat
to take a quick sip of the tea, then casually
puts it back on. Confused, Saitama asks what the
hell just happened? Big butterfly explains that
due to Chain’n’toad being extremely plain of a
person he wasn't popular in the hero rankings.
In an attempt to fix that, he started wearing
the head gear to develop a sort of character.
Thanks to these smart tricks he was able to
become just slightly popular with the kids.
When it comes to the bearer of this info
butterfly DX, well he assumes Saitama
already knows of his skills, so there's no need to
explain them. Yet and to his complete confusion,
Saitama notes that he doesnt have a
clue who he is, but he is charmed.
This physically breaks Butterfly who claims that
he’s been on TV a lot and is pretty famous online
to. Strolling off he tells them to all hold
on for a second. Bursting back into the room
fully dressed in his Hero uniform, he excitedly
says that this is what he usually looks like!
Still Saitama has to explain to him that his
place only had public broadcast, so for the
past 2 or 3 years he’s only watched, disaster and
weather channels. Plus for a semi naked butterfly,
Saitama finds him overtly hairy and asks
him to not start shedding in his room.
Next up, Forte introduces himself and says
that he uses music or more specifically the
rhythm to help him fight in battle. On top
of that, he remarks that they put him in
a fashion magazine once, however he doesn't
care about that. Saitama remains unimpressed,
wondering how working up a rhythm
each time he fights even helps him,
causing Forte to scream out in anger and
to threaten Saitama to a fight outside.
Leaving the room in preparation to throw down,
Saitama looks down to notice that just outside
his door is Black-S and Rover. Thinking that he
should probably start setting up a dog house,
he all of a sudden has an even brighter
idea. Needing a way to lighten his workload,
Saitama proposes the plan of having the loser
of his upcoming battle take care of these pets.
Walking out themselves now, Forte notices the
monkey looking thing and cruely picks it up by
his head antenna. Butterfly cant help but notice
the weird look of it and wonders if its a sort
of monster. Hearing this Black-S realizes
that he needs to continue pretending to be
a monkey if he wants to survive. Having
taken a look at these so called pets,
Forte agree’s with Saitama’s proposal of
making the loser take care of these pets.
Down in the associations parking lot now,
Chain'n'toad and Butterfly DX watch as the
two A-Class hero’s begin to face off. Forte
cockily tells his opponent that he might
end up getting hurt so no hard feelings
either way, to which Saitama states the
same thing and pleads for him to not beg
to become his disciple once he does win.
Chain’n’toad notes that moving to a rhythm isnt a
strange technique, even first rate martial artists
learn to do this. However if you dismiss Forte’s
unique fighting style that has been attainted
through countless battles as a performer, then
that fool would be in for a world of pain!
Activating his music, Forte begins showing off
his unique style of fighting with rhythm, randomly
though as he does this, Saitama tries screaming
something out to him. Due to the headphones
though Forte doesn't hear it and is run down by
a car that had just pulled into the parking lot.
Quickly getting out of the car to check what the
hell the ran into, its revealed to be the Blizzard
Group who were heading to this unknown location
earlier. Noticing someone getting out of the car,
Saitama makes sure to let her know to apologize
to this random later. Curious as to why Saitama’s
even at this Association Headquarters, Fubuki
questions what they hell he’s even doing here?
Meanwhile, in an underground parking, a
mysterious person exits their dope asf car
and is welcomed by three Hero Association staff
members. Fubuki senses that man's presence and
tells Saitama to come with her. Turning around,
she grants him permission to accompany them,
the Fubuki Group into the association, confusing
the hell out of Saitama. Grabbing his pants,
Black-S asks Saitama what they should do? Looking
over and realizing that he has beaten Forte, hands
over Black Sperm and Overgrown Rover to Butterfly
DX before leaving with Fubuki and her group.
Moving into the Associations base, the
Fubuki group makes their way down to the
special internment facility. Giving the inmates
number they intend to visit to the receptionist,
its revealed to them that, that inmate
is already being visited by someone
else. Following this meeting they are being
immediately transferred to another facility.
Due to this the receptionist lets them
know that they cant visit this person,
however with this being an emergency, Fubuki
demands to be taken their straight away!
Down on floor B13, the mysterious man is led
to a gigantic jailing cell. Opening the door,
the guard exclaims that its perfectly safe as
this person has been highly medicated. Inside
its shown that the mastermind behind the monster
association, Psykos has been incapacitated and
restrained. Making his way inside, this
random dude says that according to what
he was able to surveil during the previous
battle, this woman was able to fight on even
grounds with Tatsumaki. To their organization,
she is an extremely valuable person with a few
extraordinary abilities. He thanks the higher
up members of the Hero Association for handing
her over to them, to which its revealed that
they have already stripped her of all human
rights and labeled her as a monster. They are
free to do whatever they please with her now!
After coming up to her, the man claims that Psykos
is a sample that will help greatly in progressing
the "Tsukuyomi's research". Upon hearing the name
"Tsukuyomi", Psykos becomes slightly alert and
uses her telekinesis to assault the man, who,
also appears to be an esper and quickly blocks
her attack. Figuring that the medication wasn't
exactly the greatest, this dude launches a counter
strike and renders her unconscious with one blast.
Looking at her fall limp, he stops his attack and
notes that they cannot damage her precious brain.
Inside it of course is the awed over third eye
that they have heard so much about, an eye that
allows one to take a glimpse into the future.
One of the representatives asks if he should
deal to her some more as they have some fantastic
facilities here. Turning and revealing his
true self now, this man exclaims that its fine,
they’ll perform a very thorough examination
on her once they get back to the lab.
Meanwhile and while taking a massive elevator that
leads to underground, Saitama and the Blizzard
Group head towards the mysterious man. While on
their way there, Fubuki recalls her encounter with
Psykos during the Monster Association incident.
As they were about to battle, Fubuki addressed
her as the former vice president, Psykos “of the
third eye”. She tried appealing to her human side
and asked for the fellow esper to surrender
herself peacefully, otherwise it might harm
her actual life. Spazzing out in pure anger over
being told what to by this absolute witch again,
Psykos angrily said that Fubuki got desperate and
sealed off her powers when they were students.
NOW just when she was about to rise up to be the
strongest in the world, she stands in front of her
once again. Hearing this, Fubuki agrees and says
that yes, she used to be a self-centered person.
But back in the day when Psykos proposed the idea
of “humanity extermination while they were still
in a group class called "Society for Supernatural
Research", everyone hated the idea. Fubuki though,
all she could think of, was an overwhelming
desire to pass her sister and stand on top
of the world. If she completed that, there
wouldn't be a need for anyone else at the top.
Watching the highschool Psykos more,
Fubuki came to hate who she was,
she despised that she tried to steal
her followers away from her. On that
day she realized that Psykos was her
enemy and enemies must be crushed.
Screaming that this time, Fubuki will be crushed,
Psykos biffs a flurry of sharp stone objects down
on the ground below. Somehow powering up on an
unprecedented level, Fubuki is then seen flying up
into the sky, through the rubble and commencing
a 1v1 battle against her old schoolmate.
In a flashback, a young Psykos is seen telling
Fubuki about the increased membership in their
group and the Invisible Hand from a nearby town
wanting to pick a fight with them. Overtime,
its shown that the Invisible hand instead
offered to work under them. Wondering if
she’s getting stronger, Psykos commends
Fubuki for having powers that dwarf her
already strong abilities. Psykos at this
point was only able to lift a single human,
while Fubuki was able to
life an entire 18wheel truck.
Later in a library, Psykos is seen studying
a new ability called the "Third Eye" that
sees into the future. With this
ability, she thinks she might be
able to predict the future just like the
great prophet Shibabawa. On top of that,
it might allow her and Fubuki to finally
overthrow her evil older sister. However,
the future Psykos then sees drives her insane, she
cant seem to understand that this is the future.
Mentally insane, the next day at school the
overwhelming pain of this future caused her
to scream out that all of their future plans
are pointless. Explaining it all to Fubuki,
she instead proposed the idea of destroying
everyone. That way at least the whole human
race will be able to start over and it
wont become the disaster its certain to be.
Back to the moment they were confronting each
other during the Monster Association incident,
an already weakened Psykos was defeated and
captured by Fubuki, who wanted to know the source
of her madness. What was it that she was in the
future. Catching the falling Psykos in her arms,
Fubuki wonders what changed her, she was never
a tough person. Placing her hand on her friends
head, she senses mysterious presence floating
above them that sent a chill down her spin.
Back in the present, the Blizzard Group and
Saitama finally arrive at Psykos's interment
unit just as she is about to be taken away
by that random man. Fubuki informs everyone
present that the visitation is over and the
need to evacuate the room immediately. Due
to the information about Psykos being moved and
if Tatsumaki finds out about it, she’ll come to
finish her off. Instantly following that warning,
the roof above Fubuki is destroyed and Tatsumaki
drops into the room to finish her job. Pointing
her finger down and questioning why she’s alive,
Tatsumaki attempts to bury Psykos in rubble.
Luckily, Fubuki and the random react in time,
managing to put up an energy orb around
Psykos. Seeing the random try and attack her,
Tatsumaki with just a glance sends the
random dude shooting off into the wall.
Fubuki screams for all the representatives
to escape back to the surface and commands
her guys to start attacking her sister. Getting
reading to send a blast in her sisters direction,
it suddenly skips back in time
to a dinner date between the two.
There Tatsumaki explained that
the same guys who captured her
when she was younger are now after
Psykos. Even though she’s a monster,
Tatsumaki finds it immoral to hand her over to
anyone from that group. Instead she actually plans
to work in combination with Fubuki, while
making it look like they aren't together.
Skipping back to the fight, the random esper who
managed to survive Tatsumaki’s blow, gets back up
and knocks out the fleeing representatives, then
destroys the rooms camera’s. Slowly powering up,
he expresses a desire to make all
three of the girls into his souvenirs.
As all of the espers begin powering up sending
rubble flying, Saitama tries butting in. All
he came here to do was actually complain
to Tatsumaki for destroying his apartment,
but its obvious now that she doesn't
have a sorry bone in her body.
While pretending to hold off her sister, Fubuki
remarks that she’s lucky Saitama joined her. She
knows that he has a great strength within
him and is even playing dumb, purposefully
not realizing that he defeated Garou. Saitama
tries to say that he honestly doesn't remember,
but its not like she was even listening. She
fought Garou too and it was obvious he was
someone who had reached a peak then ascended
it. If Saitama did truly take him down,
then he must have ascended aswell. Fubuki gave
up on being the strongest a long time ago and
because of that she can make the distinction
between those who are and aren't ascended.
However, due to the powerful psychic clash
between Tatsumaki and the man from Tsukuyomi,
the ground beneath Saitama violently cracks
and he falls down to the floor below,
much to Fubuki's shock. Down on an
even lower level of the Association,
Saitama confronts many Demon-level Beings who have
been detained there. Laying there he wonders what
the hell this part of the base is. Noticing
that the base is keeping monsters as pets,
he presumes that its probably sweet
to have a dog or 2 in his apartment.
This month inside of the world of One
Punch man has had an all time high of
monster disasters. A random rich girl in
a date notes that if tones more of these
monsters keep appearing then people might
not be able to go outside! The bloke though,
he knows he’s safe! The higher ranking hero’s
all protect this area. They have an ever higher
level of security than any upscale neighborhood.
The facilities the association provides are on
par if not better than any other place and
they’ve got even more planned. There isn't
any annoying traffic and it might even become
the capital one day. Hearing all this quells
the girls fears of death, however after she
places her tea down, notices that its shaking.
Feeling what surely isn't an earthquake,
the dude denies all thoughts of it,
as this facility is constructed with
state of the art earthquake restraints.
As it all seems to come to a stop, a sudden
clash between Tatsumaki and the mysterious
dude creates a powerful earthquake that
knocks all of the rich people off their feet.
Over in the control center, hell is breaking
lose as they try and quickly discover the
location of this shaking. Noticing that its
coming from the experimental monster floor,
the man in charge screams out
to get some hero’s down there.
Back in the battle between espers and noticing
that he’s still at a slight disadvantage,
Tatsumaki mocks him asking if the poor little
guinea pig ever thought he stood a chance?
Getting distracted for a moment, Tatsumaki
notices her sister fainting after trying to
re-open the whole in the floor. In actuality
though its revealed that previously before
coming here he had implanted a sleeping
tablet in Fubuki’s daily supplements.
Taking her hostage now, he threatens
to break the deadly poison one next.
Enraged but still able to think on the spot,
Tatsumaki realizes that there’s most likely a spy
in the manufacturer of the base or someone in her
sisters group. Complementing her listening skills,
the male esper demands that Tatsumaki not resist.
Joking that he needs to make her slightly easier
to carry, Tatsumaki is suddenly forced into a
binding of psychic power. While holding her he
explains that the espers are a defective
species that need to go extinct. Throwing
up his other hand, the dude proceeds to open
the containment cage of Demon-level Monsters
that are kept on the floor beneath them.
He explains that no one would care if both
of the sisters died due to Tatsumaki’s
rage unleashing all of these monsters.
Emerging from the Fubuki group
the Spy jumps up and fly's off
to make his leave with this mysterious group.
As the plasmafeild holding back
the monsters begins to disappear,
all of the weak Fubuki members try and
close the door, but it just wont work.
With a terrifying screech, all of
the Demon-level monsters slowly
begin emerging from the floor below.
Randomly though all of the monsters
explode and Saitama busts through the
floor's entrance surprising everyone.
Getting slightly distracted for a moment,
Tatsumaki finds a way free and breaks through
the mental restraints put on her body. Instantly
the Tsukuyomi member attempts to activate the
poison pill inside of Fubuki, though to no
avail. Instead its shown that Tatsumaki,
within milliseconds of receiving her power back,
had managed to find and neutralize. She managed
to do this by copying the wavelength of her
opponent espers telekinetic signals and turning
the pill into a needle thinner than a strand of
hair. Following this, Tatsumaki pulls the needle
out of Fubuki's body and directs it towards her
enemies face. Putting up his hands to stop it,
the Tsukuyomi member can do nothing as it pierces
his hands and stabs directly into his right eye.
Noticing that he didnt die instantly from
the attack, Tatsumaki menacingly threatens
him as she intends to wring his body until all
information on the Tsukuyomi group is revealed.
Using her psychic abilities, Tatsumaki collapses
the complete room in on this random dude and
captures him inside a huge boulder-sized asteroid.
The spy desperately tries to flee the scene but
Tatsumaki glances in his direction and sends him
crashing into a nearby wall, knocking him out.
With the Tsukuyomi members defeated and the
situation solved, the Blizzard Group rushes
to their leader, showing concern for Fubuki's
wellbeing and wanting to know what just happened.
Tatsumaki furiously demands that they shut their
god damn mouths, and scolds the entire group
including Fubuki. She demands that her younger
sister breaks all ties with them, they were used
to take advantage of her and they just got lucky
this time. In all reality Tatsumaki knows that
she cant protect them all and needs to split her
sister away from them. Showing the love they have
for their leader, the Fubuki group demands to
know why, if they at least explain it to them
then maybe they can figure out a countermeasure.
Enraged with their defiance, Tatsumaki sternly
tells them that its because of their stupidity
that their leaders life was put in danger. Fubuki
doesn't need them anymore and in her eyes all of
them are just a nuisance. If they dont decide to
leave now, then Tatsumaki threatens them that
she’ll make sure they can never work again.
Fubuki screams out for her sister to stop,
however the one to grab the espers hand
and put a stop to this complete rage fest,
was none other than the bald king! Asking what
the hell he’s doing, Saitama tells her that the
two sisters are just like each other. This,
this is going to far just to lecture someone!
In another place, Air suddenly awakens in the Hero
Association hospital. Speaking up, Forte who was
also put in hospital says that he doesn't need
to worry, he’s perfectly safe here. According to
what he’s heard, Air had let his guard down for
a moment and was taken out by a random monster.
Wondering who he actually is, Forte introduces
himself to Air as the rank 31 Hero and someone
who’s a higher rank than him, so they should just
get along. Forte himself notes that he probably
isn't in the best state to judge someone, and cant
even comprehend how his opponent took him down.
Feeling the something on his neck,
and noticing a change in his voice,
a random doctor lets Air know that the damage he
received in battle was severe. To fix him they
had to surgically augment his voice box with
some mechanics. The doctors claim that they’re
specialists in cyborg science and were requested
personally by the Association to help out Air.
Seeing that he’s being ignored, Butterfly DX
asks Forte what’s getting him so riled up,
its not like he should be taking his anger out
on others to start with. Not listening to him,
Forte just goes on a fat rant about
how, once he leaves here he’s gonna
get his revenge on that douche bag named Saitama
or something. That guy acted like some dumbass,
but turned out to be one tricky genius with an
abnormal ability. Forte asks his boys if they
all saw it aswell... Saitama was right there in
front of him, then randomly out of absolutely
nowhere he was assaulted by an attack that
sent him straight to hospital. On top of that,
his ankle is broken and he has a crazy ass
whiplash. Its almost as if he was hit by a car.
Getting close to him, both of Forte’s boys
let him know that it was a car... Plus he
should probably stop using headphones during
battle, as the guy was just trying to help.
Realizing how freaking stupid he is, Forte asks
them to forget about everything he just said.
He’d honestly thought he was just like Tatsumaki
and was the owner of some cheat-level psychic
abilities. To which hearing that, butterfly
remarks that if it was her, he’d be dead.
Bringing the trio back to reality, Forte
wonders what the hell the shaking was
earlier. Knowing some of the information,
Butterfly DX says that it was some monsters
in the jailhouse going rampant, but will
go and source more info while he rests.
Meanwhile, and after having her hand grabbed
by the big man, Tatsumaki asks if he’s deaf
or something as she just told him to let go.
Saitama replies that he’s just trying to get
her to calm the actual hell down, causing the
esper to attempt to throw saitama through the
Associations base. Looking at the force being
exerted on him, Saitama wonders if this was
the same ability that sent Geno’s flying and tells
Tatsumaki that right now she’s no different power
wise from Fubuki. Fubuki screams out in horror
not wanting Saitama to enrage her sister anymore.
Just straight up pissed now, Tatsumaki screams for
him to let go and begins trying to twist the bald
mans body. Much to the surprise of the S-Class
hero, Saitama is able to endure her attack,
making her question what in the worlds
different about him. Chilling in his
own strength dimension, Saitama starts to
notice a subtle twitch with his muscles,
making Fubuki think that he’s easily
able to withstand her sisters full power.
Getting up close to him now, Tatsumaki remarks
that she thought she’d seen him somewhere before,
he’s the baldy who’s always chilling with the
Demon Cyborg. Confused as to why he’s here now,
she asks if he’s apart of the Fubuki group aswell?
Unconcerned for the child trying to escape
his grasp, Saitama yells out for Fubuki to
quickly evacuate everyone out of here before
her sister accidentally kills them. Seeing
how cute Saitama is with Fubuki, Tatsumaki
with a look im sure ive never seen before,
questions if thats the true reason as to why
he’s here now. Taking this question as asking
what he means to Fubuki, Saitama says that
its not like he’s her mate. Or her companion,
or a close friend. He’s just an acquaintance.
Hearing this news sparks a flame within the heart
of Fubuki and drops her to the floor, completely
unconscious. Looking HELLA devious herself,
Tatsumaki asks why he’d get so desperate just over
a simple acquaintance? Either way in her eyes,
she needs to test his strength levels to find
out if he truly deserves to be hanging all over
Fubuki like that. WHICH IS CRAZY! One or Murata
you guys are nuts for that hahaha, I actually
laughed so damn hard, this whole part so far!
Its unreal how continuously funny it is, every
situation Saitama is in is half serious and not.
Like even here he gets exactly what she’s saying
and even gets repulsed at the idea of it. Instead
he exclaims that its HER! She's the one dragging
him around all the time and being just a total
pain. God I love the look of the starry eyed
Fubuki just glaring at him, anyway anyways!
Amping herself up, the surroundings all begin
warping and twisting due to the power increase
in Tatsumaki's psychic output. Above, all of the
residents begin freaking out over this apparent
‘brand new building’ already suffering
some damning issues. In the control room,
Gearsper yells out that the elevator to
get to the lower floors broke. The other
dude notes that some of the clients were
in visitation with one of the prisoners,
along with a select few hero’s
who’ve also been trapped down there.
As the basement starts twisting even more,
slowly reaching the point where everyone
might be crushed, Saitama tells Tatsumaki to
stop treating people like trash. Instead and
to keep everyone safe, he grabs and pulls her
in close to his chest, causing the esper to
feel some sorta way, before forcefully jumping
towards the sky, taking Tatsumaki with him.
Looking up through the gaping whole, Fubuki notes
that its begun, Saitama vs Tatsumaki! Above them,
that electric dude cant remember his name
rn haha, yells down noticing the people
there and calls over some other Hero’s
to head down through this new whole.
Elsewhere inside of the maze that is this
new Hero Association Base, Tongue Stretcher,
Wolf Beer Bellee, and Man-Eating Capybara
manage to escape from their holding cell.
Having made their way to, what they
think is a random room, the three goons
burst into it expecting to find a few pathetic
humans. Instead they find that instead of humans,
almost every single A-Class hero is situated in
this random room. Dumbfounded with their luck,
the monsters instantly close
the door and make a run for it.
Elsewhere at the exact same time, a random family
is seen travelling towards their new condo at the
Hero Association headquarters. Knowing that the
recent influx of monsters isn't going to stop
any time soon, the father notes that the 35 year
loan is a small price to pay for them to live in
peace. Unable to even fathom how long 35 years
is, the son just begins getting hyped up over
the thought of receiving signatures from his
favorite heroes once they arrive. Suddenly a
glint of light pierces through the afternoon sky,
confusing the father who cant see what it is.
Ofcourse that sparkle in the sky was none
other than Saitama and Tatsumaki who end
up crashing and bouncing along the ground next
to the highway. Tatsumaki confusedly asks what
the hell Saitama’s upto before launching
his body into a violent spin. Whipping the
caped baldy down, she slams him into the
ground, however Saitama's grip holds firm.
A flustered Tatsumaki accuses Saitama of being
"into her" but Saitama corrects her by stating he
just doesn't want her to run away to destroy more
homes. Hearing him say run makes Tatsumaki explode
in anger, as in her mind why the hell would she
run from someone weaker than her. Letting her
hand go now, Tatsumaki instantly changes her mood
and even acknowledges Saitama strength, saying
that it isn't half bad. Pulling her hand upto his
forehead, she increases her psychic output just
slightly before flicking the caped baldy, sending
him flying back into a pile of rubble. Looking up,
Saitama notices that Tatsumaki has completely
lost it and activated her signature Tornado move.
Meanwhile in the association everyone else is
standing around the meteor sized tomb that the
agent is stuck inside. Suddenly its slashed
apart and falls to bits revealing an escape
hole that has been dug underneath the base. While
everyone realizes that the two guys have escaped,
the Tsukuyomi members find their vehicle
and boost past the guards towards freedom.
Heavily wounded and seemingly safe now, the spy
asks if Mr Apollo was alright! Looking in the side
mirror though, he quickly realizes that directly
behind them, Tatsumaki is already outside.
Seething with anger, Apollo eerily comments that
the next time he see’s her, she will be his.
Over in the battle, Tatsumaki hurls a boulder
directly at Saitama, yet he easily deflects
it. Upping her attack potency, Tatsumaki sends
a barrage of boulders towards Saitama. Vanishing
as they hit they ground, the caped baldy
then boosts straight at the reckless child.
Inside the control center of the Hero Association
base, a bunch of low class workers relay in
horror, that they've detected abnormal vibrations
approximately 2km’s away. Overhearing the
commotion and knowing that metal knight is still
unreachable, an overseeing advisor asks for them
to begin assessing the disaster level. Based off
the minimal information he’s heard, the advisor
guesses that they probably need an S-Class hero
and asks if anyone can be immobilized immediately.
Outdoors that random family who’s tryna make
their way to their new condo, start hitting
probably the fattest straight-line drifts i've
ever seen. Man is bringing back the Saudi Drift
King.... Looking through his binoculars, the
kid notices the amazing S-Class hero Tatsumaki
fighting a mysterious opponent. Of course the dude
flashing from rock to rock is none other than the
bald legend. The father who somewhat realizes how
insanely dangerous of a situation that this is,
remarks that they should probably get
away from here fast. The kid though,
who’s wanting so bad to smoke a ‘family pack’,
begs for his father to get closer as he can
almost hear her voice. Suddenly a massive
boulder is sent barreling towards to car,
luckily Saitama manages to save the
family by destroying it in time. Annoyed,
he screams out to Tatsumaki that she needs to
pay attention to what's going on around her.
Asking why he’s acting so damn pompous?
Tatsumaki swells her energy up and sends
another flurry of boulders, while screaming
that she knows what she's doing. Seeing the
attacking heading his way and figuring
that she’s probably not in the greatest
of moods. Saitama comes to the conclusion
that for now he’ll keep her company in the
desert where no buildings or people are,
then eventually she’ll wear herself out.
Having not paid enough attention though,
our dude accidentally deflects one of
Tatsumaki’s attacks in the direction of
that same family. Vanishing from sight
in an attempt to stop his own deflection.
The car is then saved by the small esper
and pulled up into the sky with her
abilities. Instantly she turns the
situation on Saitama and jokes that he needs
to pay more attention when deflecting things.
Furious, he asks the dumb ass midget
what the hell she just said to him?
LITERALLY VAIN POPPING WITH RAGE,
Tatsumaki screams that she’s going
to turn the pathetic baldy into a vial
of farming fertilizer. Dropping the
car to the ground and leaving the family
absolutely frittered with what they went
through. The psychotic esper reactivates
her terrible tornado ability and begins
sending even more pieces of rubble in
the direction of the now fleeing baldy.
Curious as to why he’s fleeing now, she
charismatically jokes that this is pathetic,
there is no way she’d ever be able to entrust
Fubuki to someone like him. Telling him that
he needs to leave and get the hell away
from her, Saitama scoff’s at just how
bizarre this has all become, but thinks
that all he wants to do is just go home.
With his motivation plummeting, Tatsumaki
launches a psychic attack that blows off
Saitama's jacket. Not done, she follows up and
sends forth a blast that manages to knock the
caped baldy off his feet. Flying across a random
parking lot, Saitama is then hit by another few
energy attacks that send him hurling miles across
the baron landscape, towards the closest city.
Meanwhile, back at the Hero Association
Headquarters and realizing that now with
Tatsumaki making her intentions clear, there's
no possible way to keep her group together.
Approaching her with their heads down, the Fubuki
group all apologize to their leader for being
unable to do anything in the previous battle. They
claim that if given another chance they will never
make that mistake again, all she needs to do
is advise them on what to do about Tsukuyomi.
Unconcerned for these weaklings, Fubuki just tells
them she’s done. From today the Fubuki group is
disbanded because everyone else was too useless.
Standing their like stunned mullets, all the group
is able to do is watch as Fubuki fly's up into
the sky, telling them to leave and not follow her.
Meanwhile in N-City, the A-class hero Feather
is beaten and heavily injured by a random group
of foes. One of the gang members joke that
he went wild for a bit and did manage to
take a few of their guys down; however with
the injuries Feathers taken in the process,
there’s no-way he can fight any longer. Turns
out Feather had only battled this notorious ‘Iron
Fist Gang’ with the intention of freeing a female
hostage. Calling him an idiot for getting fooled,
they ask the hero for any final words, only for
the Hero to ask about this random girls safety.
Scoffing at just how mentally deficient this
hero is, the underling screams out for Erika
to show herself. Turns out that Feather already
knew this chick, and was actually being fooled
by her. She was never his woman, instead BIG
IRON, the boss of the Iron Fist is her man.
Stunning and unable to take in this cruel piece
of information. Feather can only listen as Erica
explains about the first time she was sent
out as a decoy to distract him from finding
the gang. She thanks him for being so dumb he
couldn't pick up on her terrible acting. From
the moment he met her while crying, she could
see the intent on his face to fix the situation,
he truly is a model hero. Yet, she could
barely even keep herself from laughing.
Laughing himself now, Feather
notes that she is indeed right,
she is one of the worst actors he’s ever meet. As
tears begins to drop form in her eyes, BIG IRON,
the man himself barges onto the scene
and questions as to why they’re having
so much trouble with a singular rat. Seeing
that he’s already on the verge of collapse,
Big Iron threatens to finish off
the A-Class with a single shot.
Slowly rising to his feet and mention
that this is actually perfect,
with no hostage it means he can
fully let loose. He yells out and
demands that Erica watch this, this
here will be his climax as a hero!
Remixing the entire scuffle, Feather is all
of a sudden taken out by a flying caped baldy
who uncontrollably smashed through the wall
behind him. Looking at the burly boys all
in front of him, Saitama quickly apologizes
for the damage but asks for them to send the
bill to the lady behind him. Looking over
and seeing a bunch of guys on the ground,
he yells out for someone to call an ambulance,
as everyone here is in terrible shape.
Jumping up into the cut out Saitama
made when he entered, the baldy tells
her that its dangerous to blast him through a
building. Tatsumaki though is just like bruh,
your the one who ended up blasting though it.
Whipping his head back n forth between each party,
the baldy screams that its her fault
for launching in through the sky.
The group themselves all just stand their
sweating in fear as behind the baldy,
the number 2 hero Tatsumaki the tornado of
terror has entered the building. Instantly
the boss of the gang assumes Feather broke
his promise and called the hero’s out here.
Screaming out he tells his men that a single
S-Class hero isn't strong enough to contend
with them. Saitama trys telling him to chill, but
the boss pounds down apon the A-Class hero’s head,
only to instantly be counter attacked
by one of Saitama’s basic punches.
Having watched their boss get sent into the
stratosphere, Saitama non-chalantly asks who
they’re meant to even be. Rushing forth all of the
Iron Fist Gang attempt to exact revenge, however,
Tatsumaki demands that they shut it. Her and him
are already in the middle of a little something.
A little while later we see that all those
dastardly Iron Fist members have all been taken
care of and Feather has regained consciousness.
Erica mentions that they S-Classes vanished
like a storm in the night after dealing with
the enemies. Slowly making his own approach,
Feather tries to tell her that he was never
tricked. Instead its probably best they
forget everything about the past, so that
now, now she can be free like she wanted.
Unconcerned for Feather, Erica mentions
that the one who saved her was Tatsumaki
and she needs to send her a letter of
appreciation. Staring into the distance,
Feather knows that everything is now resolved
but he feels as if he was hit by a car. Know
that he said this fight was going to be
his climax, Feather makes the decision to
return home and cry himself to sleep in an
attempt to forget this day ever happened.
Meanwhile in H-City an emergency
evacuation warning is sounding,
letting all of the civilians know about a
nearby monster that has suddenly appeared.
After recent considerations this monsters
disaster level has been adjusted from Demon
to Dragon. The warning recommends that all
personal evacuate the entirety of H-City,
but pleads with them to remain
calm in these trying times.
The disaster level dragon monster Kenzan Rat
is continuing its destructive rampage. So
far the eastern portion of H-City
is almost completely destroyed,
if this keeps up... then Human Civilization
could possibly be in danger. At-least thats
exactly how it feels as if your on the
ground! Its reported that all police,
fire fighters and hero’s who were in
the area have been completely wiped out.
Coming in to save the day though, its been heavily
reported through online forums that the goat,
S-Class hero, Metal Bat is on the verge
of making his appearance in H-City.
Cheering for her brother to make it their in
time, we flash over to see a sweaty Metal Bat
boosting it towards the monster and complaining
about how he’s gonna miss out on his precious
cat having kittens. Pissed cause how is it even
possible he’s the only S-Class hero available,
Metal notes that if something happens
to his cat, he’ll legit merc a random.
Sliding into the monsters line of sight,
Metal calls out to it and complains
that because of this thing arriving all
transport was shut down and he’s already had
to run a freaking marathon to just get here.
However, before he even has the opportunity
to exact revenge on this Rat, Kenzan is simply
headshot and killed as collateral damage in
battle between Saitama and Tatsumaki. Screaming
that he’s a stubborn loser, Tatsumaki proceeds
to throw Saitama through another 3 buildings.
Coming to a stop, Saitama tells the esper to
relax, like the whole reason for coming out
here to start with was to prevent damage.
Metal Bat having watched this and just not
in the mood after sprinting all the way to
the scene, decides to calm down and go home.
Remember how Sweet Mask was over at that
meeting shunning the bubbly boys or whatever,
well turns out the three buildings
Tatsumaki three Saitama threw was
directly opposite the building Mask was in.
Noticing they have gone far from their original
location, Saitama suggests to Tatsumaki that
both of them head back. Tatsumaki at first seems
cooperative, dropping down and agreeing with him,
but after he points out the direction they should
travel. She proceeds to grab Saitama by his clean,
shiny bald head and leads him back to their
original location by running his head into
the ground at the same time. Looking back
while being dragged, Saitama points out that
there’s someone behind them. Breaking into
an inner monologue, Tatsumaki knows that if
he’s able to keep up with them, then he must be a
monster or a hero. Genius deductive skills their.
Turns out the feign behind them is the
ball banging legend Speed-o-Sound Sonic,
who for some reason had a feeling that the
man being treated like a ragdoll was none
other than Saitama. Unconcerned for the
previous scuffle, Speed throws a bunch of
his weapons forth in an attempt to finally end
his rivals life. These special ninja shurikens
have been specifically engineered into a homing
version that will track its target then explode.
Noticing them, Tatsumaki nonchalantly redirects
the shurikens back at the ninja catching him
completely by surprise. In an instant he begins
dodging each of his own attacks, yet he fails to
notice a nearby dog pooping on the floor and
accidentally steps in it. Losing his balance,
Speed curses Saitama while simultaneously
getting hit by his own exploding shurikens.
After seeing that there now back at their
initial location, Saitama breaks loose from
Tatsumaki's grip, astonishing her with his
speed before telling her that she can feel
free to rampage here! Annoyed at him looking
down on her, Tatsumaki clarifies that she is
actually the one testing Saitama and claims
that due to his insolence she should go all
out and put him in his place. LITERALLY
CHILLING with his hand in his pocket,
Saitama tells her to go all-out on
him, which once again surprises her.
Back inside the Hero Association headquarters,
many frustrated members of the Blizzard Group
quit being Hero’s after Fubuki's decision to break
up her group. This is just mainly because to them,
this group made them feel apart of something
bigger and stronger. Now with no leader they
lack any direction and aren't strong enough
themselves to compete with stronger Hero’s.
However, Eyelashes isn't done and even manages
to motivate the few remaining loyal members to
follow him as he starts climbing towards
the surface in an attempt to find Fubuki.
Up on the surface, Fubuki witnesses
tornadoes, along with a multitude of
differing sized boulders, smashing into and
devastating the landscape due to Tatsumaki's
increased psychic output. She screams out
to her sister that this is to much and she
needs to stop, but is quickly forgotten about
as Tatsumaki beams Saitama through the sky.
Over in the new base, King is seen at
the entrance of Saitama's apartment and
is panicking due to the surrounding
catastrophe. Wondering where Saitama
could possibly be at a time like this,
our bald prophet suddenly shows up,
crashing into the wall and telling King that
he’s currently too busy to play fighting games
with him cause he’s dealing with something.
Curious as to who he’s fighting, King inquires,
only to find out its this lil pipsqueak called
Tatsumaki. Having heard Saitama make fun of her,
Tatsumaki dives in for a kick but misses
and instead crashes into the wall. Of course
King catches a glimpse of Tatsumaki's underwear,
stunning him. Not giving it away, King just stands
there looking composed and ready for anything
as Tatsumaki glides back towards the bald man.
As the intense showdown continues to
evolve, it sends even more tremors in
the direction of the Hero Association.
Forte and Air to wonder what is going
on, even cockily mentioning that they might
head out to save the day. Scaring the life
out of Forte, Saitama crashes into the wall just
above his room. Confused he inquires as to why
he’s out here, prompting Saitama to ask him about
how his injuries are healing. Continuing to tell
the young hero to stay in bed, the caped
baldy leaps from the side of the building,
back towards the midst of destruction.
After seeing the destruction that his
fellow A-Class hero left to join, Forte decides
to wait a while before his rematch with him.
Arriving at the surface themselves, the
remnants of the blizzard group is left
gobsmacked after seeing just how out of
control Tatsumaki is. They know that if
they want to stick with Fubuki though,
they need to be marked by this beast.
Swooping in over the C-Class Hero’s, Tatsumaki
knows she ended up miscalculating the outputted
power of her limits limit. To start with
she was meant to be testing this guy,
yet its all flipped on its head now. Up until
now, there has truly never been an opponent
that was able to take her head on. In all
actuality she was enjoying this battle as
before it she’d assumed that the only person
capable of standing against her was blast.
Needing to bring this pointless show of strength
to an end, Tatsumaki begins tearing up the ground
and contorting all of the rubble into two
large waves that clash into each other. Apon
forming a tunnel like structure, the esper then
collapse it apon the ant sized man underneath.
Not even a fraction of a second later, Saitama
performs an effortlessly unharmed swing,
throwing his arm up and dispersing all
of the rubble around him. Dropping to
the ground exhausted due to the
psychic output, Saitama jokes
that she doesn't need to push herself and
should still have enough strength to talk.
Snapping at him, the esper catches
Saitama in an orb of her psychic energy,
however he’s so damn heavy that she’s barely
able to even pick him up of the floor. Asking
why she’s looking so grumpy? Saitama re-iterates
that he isn't her enemy. Like he mentioned before,
its just she views the lives of human
relationships too lightly. For example
right now she's being stopped by the
power of Fubuki’s mere acquaintance.
Hearing those words and after
failing to send Saitama into space,
Tatsumaki slowly loses consciousness from
overusing her power. Dropping to her knee’s
she starts to remember how Blast told her that she
shouldn't ever expect someone to come save her.
Moments after Blast had saved her, Tatsumaki
reunited with Fubuki in order to protect her.
After noticing she was followed by four
Tsukuyomi members, Tatsumaki disposed of
them before once again asking Fubuki to come with
her. The shock of witnessing her sister's violent
acts caused the 5-year-old Fubuki to awaken
her psychic power and push Tatsumaki away.
As this self-reflection of her’s continues,
she comes to see it was her that dragged
Fubuki to a harsh fate. Because of that,
she now feels like she has the responsibility
to protect her without relying on anyone else.
Actually crazy to realize the reason behind
Tatsumaki wanting to constantly protect
her sister, was because she is the reason she
developed powers and now feels responsible for it.
Awaking in a bright place, Tatsumaki see’s Blast
standing in the distance. Walking upto him,
she asks if this is where he’s
been all along. Seeing him leave,
she cant help but run after him
and plead for him to not leave.
Throughout the story so far, the only one to
set Tatsumaki free was Blast. Due to this,
she grew an obsessive excessive expectation
of Blast. She sought respect from the one
that free’d her and needed someone
to guide her on a better road.
Catching upto him know, Tatsumaki
just says that she tried really hard,
but nothing ever works out. She doesn't
want everyone to hate and be afraid of her,
but if they aren't then things will
just end up how they were before.
Standing there with tears in here eyes,
she questions the top-ranking hero about
what she should do? When suddenly a beam
of light begins cutting its way
into this already glistening realm.
Of course she was just waking up and
above her was the gleaming bald king,
Saitama looking down and
asking if she was alright.
Saitama praises Tatsumaki's abilities, and pats
her on the head while stating that if Tatsumaki
can rampage without destroying other people's
stuff, she would make a great hero. As Saitama
turns to leave, Fubuki arrives and tells Tatsumaki
she has separated from her group. Joking that
she likes the new attitude but it doesn't
seem as if her own group understands yet,
Fubuki turns around to see all of her
loyal members running up behind her.
Seeing Tatsumaki glaring at the
lot of them, Eyelashes along with
a few of the other members garner up the
courage to asks her if she’ll allow them
to work below Fubuki. Done with these mice,
Tatsumaki raises her hand to annihilate them,
however its Fubuki who jumps infront and
attacks her own men with a hell storm
blast. Knowing that they came back here
to confront Tatsumaki, Fubuki questions
what they hell they can even do? when they cant
fend off her drastically weaker psychic powers.
Actually confused with what the fuck is going on
right now, Saitama and Tatsumaki just stand their
watching the most neuro divergent C-Class
scuffle they’ve ever seen. Questioning why
Tatsumaki doesn't just let them all go at it,
she just yaps back that its none of his concern.
Not listening, Saitama continues that back while
he was job hunting he wasn't even able to beat a
wolf level threat before starting proper
muscle training. Right now Fubuki’s team
is all pathetically weak, however he thinks that
there is truly no telling what their limit may be.
Agreeing with statement, Tatsumaki tears
her younger sister away and explains that
originally she came here to deal with Psykos.
In the end she overused to much power on a
random battle and because of that has
decided to let everyone off the hook.
Turning and glaring at the group, she exclaims
that if anything does happen to her sister,
then she will never forgive them! After
hearing them all agree, she finally turns
to Saitama and tells him that this test of
theirs isn't exactly over yet. At any time,
whenever she may feel like it, she might
show up and surprise him with another test!
Suffering a level of depression
not yet reached by man, Saitama
disagrees as thats the last damn thing he wants.
Still nearby and having listened,
Fubuki is left blown away that her
sister actually followed his orders!
Moments later, Saitama tells
Tatsumaki to chill out and not
destroy anything else before finally
making his way back to his apartment.
Shooting up into the sky, we see that
after the intense battle has come to
an end and the landscape was destroyed,
apart from one minor whole in the base,
the entire association itself remained unscathed.
Having made the long walk of shame home,
Saitama enters his apartment and comes
to the conclusion he needs to get a
new pair of shoes and some clothes.
Upon looking up though he, just like previously,
discovers that three A-class heroes; Forte,
Butterfly DX, and Chain’n’toad are waiting
for him! Wondering what the hell they’re
doing here now, Butterfly perks up and lets
him know that Forte has something to say!
Apologizing for their first meeting, Forte
legit starts glazing Saitama up, asking if
he needs any new clothes or shoes and if he didnt
mind he could bring some old sets over for him!
Creeped out with the sudden switch up,
Forte tries to say that its because they’re
all A-Class buddies and he’s just trying to be
friendly! Sensing the awkwardness the group makes
their leave, still Forte tells Saitama that if
anything does bother him, come and let him know!
After the trio of heroes departed from Saitama’s
apartment, Butterfly DX expressed his bewilderment
over Forte’s abrupt change, questioning if the
car knocked a different personality into him.
Knowing a greater secret though, Forte
disclosed that he witnessed Saitama’s
fighting while at the hospital. Compared to
them, his movements were out of this world
and he honestly doubts all 3 of them would even
last 10 seconds against him in a true fight.
Telling him to relax, Forte continues elaborating
on how those previous earthquakes weren’t caused
by mere monsters. It was the impact from his
fighting! Turning and pointing out the pets,
he states that they better look after them and
do their best to get Saitama on their side!
At the Demon-Level Monster Containment Level,
three A-class heroes – Stinger, Lightning Max,
and Blue Fire arrived to investigate the
situation. After inspecting the mess,
Lighting Max assumes that most of the monsters
on this floor were wiped out by each other. Blue
who was also investigating couldn't come to
a solid conclusion on why association would
take such risks containing a bunch of dangerous
monsters below them. The Fubuki group though try
explaining that it wasn't a monster fight and
instead it was a single A-Class who took them
all out. Asking if they all just saw something,
they re-iterate that they were telling the truth!
In the meantime, the other Fubuki members confront
the executives of the Hero Association and
accuse them of defiantly knowing something about
Tsukuyomi. Instead of fessing up, the executives
explain that they just happened to have some
spare time and wanted to check the area out.
Realizing that they probably fell for a cruel
scheme, Gearsper explains to the other people
around that Tsukuyomi is the name of a secret
society. The only reason he even knows of it is
because there has been an urban legend about them
inside of the psychic circles. However he thinks
that its all just a complete farce. Instead it
makes more sense for the surviving members of
the monster association to come back and kidnap
their leader under the guise of some new group.
With everyone somewhat agreeing with his
statement, Fubuki calls out to Mr McCoy,
one of the executives to have a chat
about something. Entering another room,
Fubuki confronts McCoy and asks him what
the hell he’s planning here. If it wasn't
for ‘her’, all of the members of her group
would've been turned into monster food.
Fessing up, McCoy goes on to detail that they’ve
been keeping monsters here for a top-secret weapon
that is currently being designed by Metal Bat.
Wanting more info, Fubuki raises a document and
asks for what in the world this massive
sum of money paid to the association was.
Sweating balls over being found out,
Fubuki’s genius hacker notes that the
lines of code he has are probably some of
the worst he’s ever seen. To which Fubuki
jokes that it would be such a scandal for
the world to find out about this news.
Immediately, Mr McCoy drops his act and asks
what it is that Fubuki actually wants. With
a grin of pleasure, Fubuki goes on to
lay out her devious plan. Pretty much,
she wants to take all of the monsters that have
died, turn the cams off and lay them out up on
the surface. That way, Tatsumaki’s rampage
can be marked off as her fighting against
these demon level threats. Plus if they
manage to fix both of those issues at once,
all of the rich folk will gain some trust
back in the security of their homes.
Starting to cackle, McCoy agree’s
with Fubuki’s proposal, and Tatsumaki
subsequently brought the monster remains to
the surface, as per the agreement. However,
it turned out to be a ruse, as one of the
remains had a special someone hidden inside.
Pulling up next to a clump of monster,
Fubuki used her abilities to tear hear old
friend out and into her car. Following this,
the group steps on the gas and accomplishes
their original goal they set out to achieve.
Simultaneously, the news broadcast of the
incident brought Tatsumaki into the spotlight,
as apparently she repelled them all on her own.
All around the city, literally everyone except
one man was overjoyed for this massive feat. Of
course, Saitama and subsequently Genos think its
complete crap. Genos even gets on the phone to
file a major complaint for this incredulous act.
In the aftermath of the incident, the Hero
Association headquarters soon discovered
that Psykos had gone missing. Apparently
she was able to escape through a hole in
the floor or ceiling of the parking lot.
Being called there to answer for this,
Tatsumaki feigned responsibility and
began searching for the missing esper.
Watching her leave and with a grin on his
face, McCoy calls out to her saying that he
didnt realize she could be o so remorseful.
Its almost as if she’s being strangely kind!
Turning and looking more cooked than ever,
Tatsumaki leaves saying that its just
somedays she happens to be in a good mood!
Meanwhile, Child Emperor who thought
the incident was kinda sussy,
did a little digging. After a little hacking,
he quickly came to see that the entire
incident was nothing but fraud and coverups!